Next we'll have the Office of Fleet Management.
Keep looking around the room for Jack Christie for this one, but I
don't think he's here's.
I'd like to welcome Director Gary Glask
and Mr. Ray Cruz. Good afternoon.
My name is Gary Glaskok, and I'm the director of the Fleet Management Department.
I'll be presenting the department's proposed operating budget for fiscal
year 2023. Along with me is Ray Cruz of the
Finance Department. Ray serves as the Chief
Financial Officer for Fleet Management.
Next slide, please.
I'll start with some department information for reference purposes.
Our mission is to provide the City of Houston with best value fleet
management services. We operate 27 maintenance
garages and 67 refueling sites to service
a little more than 13,700 vehicles and pieces
of equipment. Next slide, please.
Fleet Management is a revolving fund department.
Our proposed operating budget for fiscal year 2023
is $98,930,411.
This budget will provide for a little more than 381
full time positions that are deployed within
five different programs. The first of these programs is
the Director's Office, which handles the strategic planning, policy making
and personnel administration for the department. The budget of the
Director's Office covers restricted account charges by other
city departments, including Human Resources, Finance and
Hits. Our Operation division performs
the maintenance work in the garages and oversees the repair work done
by our contractors. 61% of the
total Fleet Management budget is allocated to the operations
program to cover the cost of labor, spare parts
and contracted services. The Fuel
Management Group oversees fuel, inventories and service station
maintenance. Their budget pays for the gasoline and diesel
used by city vehicles. Our Customer
Service Division handles the distribution of replacement parts, our material
and services contracts, as well as our motor pool or
fleet share. The customer service budget is largely
driven by labor costs. And then finally, our Asset
Management Division oversees capital, program, vehicle,
onboarding tracking and eventual disposal. They also
manage our data collection system as well as our reporting systems.
In addition to labor costs, the asset management budget covers
software, maintenance and related expenses. Next slide,
please. This slide
provides historical reference for our proposed budget and major expense categories.
Again, we are a revolving fund department, so the listed
values reflect both our revenues and expenses.
In the top table, you'll see that we're proposing a $3.9 million
or 4.2% increase in operating expenses
compared to current year. Moving down to
the expense category table, our personnel expenses
are increasing by 3.6%, while the cost of
supplies is going up $1.8 million or 9%.
We're seeing a 1% increase in restricted account charges
as well as an increase of $535,000
for contracted services. And I'll provide a little more detail
on these increases a little later in the presentation. Next slide,
please. Here's a
graphical representation on how the funding of our proposed budget
is being allocated. Labor is the largest slice of
the pie at 37% of total, followed by
fuel at 25% and parts.
At 16%, we plan to spend roughly $9
million on Outsider Contracted Services and
$5.6 million on tires.
The $4.1 million slice of pie labeled Other
Restricted accounts includes what we pay other city departments
for their services. And finally, the 3 million in
the other miscellaneous expenses will fund items such as office supplies,
employee uniforms, diagnostic software and tools.
Next slide, please.
Fleet Management receives revenues from our client departments to
cover their fuel and vehicle maintenance expenses.
Roughly 74 million in revenue will be sourced from the general fund
departments, while 23 million is expected from
the departments that operate with enterprise funds. Another 2.8
million will come from special grants and funds.
Next slide.
This table lists the expenditure changes included in the proposed budget
compared to current year. In the top section of the table,
you'll see that our operating budget for fiscal year 22
is $94.9 million. This amount
includes a $4.6 million adjustment
that was made to cover fuel price increases.
The middle section of the table highlights the significant adjustments of the
proposed fiscal year 23 budget. All of the increases
are limited to contractual or mandated adjustments.
The sum of these adjustments results in the 4.2%
budget increase compared to current year. Next slide,
please. Here's some
additional detail on the budget adjustments of the previous slide.
Personnel costs are going up approximately $997,000
due to the Hope salary increase along with the rising costs
of health and pension benefits. Our headcount for
fiscal year 23 actually drops by three compared
to current year. Fuel expenses go up
$240,000. This increases
on top of the $4.6 million adjustment that was made
to the current year budget for fuel.
A $2 million Escalation for the purchase of parts will cover
rising costs resulting from inflation and supply chain
issues. We're also increasing the cost of contracted
services by $1 million. This adjustment will
handle Escalating contractor rates as well as provide us
with some additional contracting capacity. The $379,000
reduction in program expenses is a sum
of cuts over multiple budget line items as
well as the elimination of onetime expenses that occurred
during the current year. And this concludes
the Fleet Management Fiscal Year 2023 budget presentation.
We've got next slide there, but I think we'll skip over it for the sake
of time. Really isn't related to the budget,
and we'll go to questions. Thank you, Council Member
Ed Pollard. Thank you, Chair. I have a couple of
questions. First one is from Council Member Michael
Kubash, who's not with us at the moment. His question
is how do we purchase gasoline,
diesel and CNG? Do we buy it each
month or is there a contract out for it each year?
We purchase it under contract and we're currently in the
third year of the contract. We've got two one year options that
are available. The current term
ends, I believe it's in September of this year. And that
vendor is for all different types of gasoline. No, we've actually
got one vendor for gasoline and
another vendor for diesel.
And we actually ride the contract that's
owned by Metro. And so Metro's fuel Buying,
in addition to the City's fuel buying, provides us with some purchasing leverage.
Second question is, last year we had a budget amendment
that was put forth that we discussed within BFA that talked
about the idea of putting advertisements
on city vehicles as a way to generate revenue. I knew we were
doing maybe a study or an analysis on whether or not that
is feasible, something that would be attractive to the city.
Are you familiar with that? Where do we stand on that? I was not involved
in those particular discussions, but I can say that at a previous employer,
we did take advantage of that particular opportunity and there
was some revenue that was generated. Of course, this was using transit
buses. So there's a much larger canvas compared to the opportunities
that are provided with city vehicles. Chair, did we ever get any feedback on that
after we did that BFA meeting regarding that topic?
No, not that I recall. Okay, I'll follow up with you on that.
Thank you. This is a quick follow up. The contracts
for the gas, diesel and LNG, are they a fixed price or a variable?
They're variable price and they're based on the Platts marketing
index. And so our price is relative to whatever that
index is doing. So as prices rise we didn't do any hedging.
We did not do any hedging, but we are considering it at the moment.
In fact, we've had some discussions with both our finance group
and legal as well as Metro because they're doing a little hedging right now
to see if we can offer the city some protection going that route.
Council member Amy Peck. Thank you. Thank you, Director,
for the presentation. As costs are increasing
for gas, for just maintenance, for everything related to fleet,
how closely are you working with the departments when they're looking
at their budgets? Are you telling them, here's what we can expect for increase in
costs and then they're doing their budget accordingly? Or are they just kind of left
up to determining how much those costs might go up?
Yes, we work with the departments regularly and
we're actually seeing some unprecedented times.
And so we're seeing some really high
increase for the cost of vehicles. We're also seeing high
increases for parts, but we're also seeing supply chain issues.
And so what used to take six months to get is
now taking up to 1824 months for delivery.
And so what we're asking our departments to do is to focus on the critical
vehicles in their shift within their fleet because they're
much harder to get compared to previous.
And so that's where our attention is at the moment. Thank you.
Council Member Sally Alcorn, along those same lines
as Council Member Peck, I noticed in the budget book you've got under fuel
management there's a decrease, $3 million
in that division. So I don't know if
that's just because of when we were
okay, so there was a decrease made relative to
the current year budget. My understanding is that based
on fuel prices, when we put the budget together,
the cost of fuel is actually much less than what it currently
is. We've had a spike since then. Will you probably make an adjustment to
this? Because that did catch my eyes when I was looking at the divisions and
how could fuel management be going down in these days?
So we increased the budget by $4.5
million during journal appropriations. So that kind of changed the balance
and fuel for next year. So the original budget for fuel was $20 million.
We increased it to $24 million, but the FY 23
budget was 24 million and change. Okay,
got it. Thank you. Not due to more LNG or
electric cars or it's strictly that straight.
Okay. Council member, abbey Cayman. Thank you. And Director, thank you
for the presentation. I was hoping you wouldn't skip over the
last page as it relates to fleet electrification.
Really quickly off the top of your head, where are we
in terms of percentage of total fleet moving towards
hybrid or electric? In terms of percentage?
Let's see. We're still very small. We're making
incremental gains, I should say.
Council just approved the purchase of 97 vehicles.
We're getting ready to bring another package of roughly ten vehicles
within probably the next month or so.
One of the big issues that we're dealing with when it comes to purchasing
electric vehicles is the limited capital budget that's available.
And so as I mentioned earlier, the focus
on capital and how we use that capital is
on critical equipment. So the bulk of the money
is going to police cars, fire trucks, and refuge
trucks. Whatever is left over gets allocated to
light duty vehicles. And that's where our opportunity
is, to fund electric vehicles. Now, what we're working
on now is we're trying to take advantage of the current used
car market and sell off as many underutilized
city vehicles as possible. We're using those proceeds
to buy electric vehicles now. And one
of the reasons I'm asking is, one is fuel continues
to increase. We have supply shortages, vehicles that are
way beyond their lifespan, and we need to continue to move
towards the mayor's goal of a renewable energy fleet.
However, I also know that the fire department, during their
presentation with their lease program for certain vehicles,
is showing improvements in returns on that. Are we
considering that for other parts
of the fleet, city of Houston fleet? Yes, ma'am.
So, as I mentioned previously, we're in some unprecedented times here.
Vehicle costs, as well as the ability to
source parts to make repairs. We've got examples
of fire trucks that were damaged in accidents earlier this year
that are taking a year to 18 months to get repaired simply
because parts aren't available. And so
we have to start thinking strategically on how we ensure
that our emergency services are sustained. And to
that end, on top of that, we're having lots
of difficulty, as I've heard the other departments mentioned,
recruiting mechanics. And so as we look
at our current situation, we being fleet management
and our in house personnel focusing on that critical equipment.
And we do think there's going to be some opportunities for increased leasing
to help manage what's going on with the light duty vehicles.
Let me back into you. Council Member Carolyn evan Shabaz.
Thank you, Mayor Brutam. Thank you so much for this presentation.
I just wanted to ask a question. Have there been any concerns
about the theft of catalytic converters? Have any of
them been stolen and are there any financial implications
involved with protecting them with the fleet?
Yes, ma'am. We did have a number of catalytic converters stolen knocking
on wood, but it has been over six to
eight months since we've recorded any thefts.
I'm going off of memory here, but I want to say that the city
has spent almost $400,000 in making repairs
to those vehicles that were vandalized.
Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman. Thank you,
Director. Do we know how many employees right now are utilizing our fleet share program?
I don't have that number. Off the top of my head, I will say that
over the past year, we've worked very hard to get fleet share up.
We saw numbers drop dramatically during the pandemic,
and we're now starting to see an increase.
What we've also been doing is for our client departments
offering long term fleet share leases to cover their immediate
needs. Our purpose is to get as many
of the pool vehicles out in use, because they're
not doing anything for the city when they're just sitting. And so I
believe we're up, and I'll get back to you. But I believe we're
at 50% right now, which is an
improvement from I think we started somewhere around 30% earlier
this year. But I'll be happy to get those details to you. Thank you.
We'll submit all of these questions and a few others just to follow up in
terms of electrification process progress. Thanks,
Director Glascock. We have three public speakers here.
Our first will be Jason Oliver.
Good afternoon. Thank you all for the presentation.
I think the first question kind of going along with what Council Member came
in, was talking about, what's the kind of plan
to budget for electrical vehicle charging infrastructure?
I know that's going to be, of course, the electrification of the vehicles
is important, but also the infrastructure for charging is
vital as well. Right. So the purchase of
infrastructure to recharge the electric vehicles is made under the capital
program. We're also using the proceeds from vehicle
sales to buy chargers as well. And so
our idea currently is that we are going to need one charger
for each electric vehicle that we purchase, at least initially.
Okay. And then the vehicle lease program,
what do we know about the environmental impact of that?
Because it seems like while it might
be cost effective, it has a significant environmental impact that might kind
of offset what we're doing with the electrification.
Well, in terms of environmental impact, I would say that the
lease program has the same impact as
purchasing a new vehicle. And so basically, what we're doing
is pulling an older vehicle with older emissions,
a higher emitting vehicle off the street, and replacing it with a
newer vehicle. So I guess, in summary,
anytime we can replace an old vehicle, we're improving the environmental
impact, even if it's just being bought,
because it's like a year or so, right. With some of these vehicles or the
timing, so they won't be that old. In many
cases, we are replacing model year 2000
vehicles with these leases, and those vehicles,
when they were built, had much more lenient emissions requirements
compared to current year vehicles. And so just in that
switch out alone, we provide for some environmental benefit.
Got you. Thank you. Saba Blanding.
Hey, good afternoon. I have a question
similar to Jason's, just in terms of environmental impact,
fuel consumption appears to be fairly consistent, around 10 million gallons
annually. And I'm wondering if you all have
any initiatives in place or proposed to significantly
decrease fuel consumption. Well, we do. We have
the targets of the Climate Action Plan to replace
all the non emergency vehicles with electric vehicles
by year 2030. And then we also have a
vehicle selection criteria we use. So when vehicle
purchases or leases are proposed to our department by our client
departments, we look at a couple of different things. We look at the
application, how the vehicle is being used, and then we
look at the market to see, is there an electric vehicle available?
If there is and it fits in the application, then we
make the decision to purchase that electric vehicle.
If an electric vehicle is not available, then we look
to the market to see if a hybrid vehicle is available. And if
there is, then we'll go hybrid. If we cannot satisfy the application
with either an EV or a hybrid, then we
purchase the conventional vehicle. Okay. Thank you,
Mr. Bernard Butler.
It's actually broderick like Matthew broderick.
Sorry. Thank you for the presentation.
And I don't mean to be critical. With all due respect, it was
sobering, but I appreciate the honesty of
why we as citizens walk
around and see that Tesla is putting fueling
stations in the HEB in
Heights in Montrose. And it's kind of amazing, right?
He's not a city government. He's richest man in the world.
But for you to tell me that you're not over 2% because we
can't get to this magical fleet of
electric vehicles is very sobering. I would think that the
soon to be third largest city in the country would
have been leaps and bounds like Austin or
some other place like that. But that's
just a statement. I don't expect an answer. But I
am very interested in the second part when you said you don't have mechanics.
Well, in northeast Houston, where I am, we have a community
college that we need to have someone have a strategic partnership with
to teach young millennials to be actually
mechanics. And not maybe old school mechanics, but mechanics of hybrids
and fuel vehicles. So please give that some consideration going
forward, looking down the road. Absolutely. And I might add that,
in fact, we've got our Chief of Staff in the crowd here and we have
made some pretty significant strides in reaching out to community
colleges as well as high schools. The high school
mechanic programs have proven to be very productive
in finding and recruiting employees.
And so we're pressing very hard with those learning institutions
to try to get anything we can to help us out. The only
person got to compete with is Chief Pena. He wants to be firemen. But if
you get a couple of mechanics out of it, not a problem. Thank you.
Thank you. And thank you,
Mr. Glaxcock and Mr. Cruz. This concludes
a Fleet Management Department workshop. So we will now adjourn
for a second and begin our budget workshop
up on the Housing Department. Thank you.